okay and we're live what's up guys I
should probably pause that here we go
alright let's put some music on I need
to put some music on for myself I don't
know if I can I should be able to post
stuff in my own chat there we go enjoy
some tunes with me listen to some music
that's awesome i can finally post links
in my own chat thanks youtube all right
what's up guys um let's get this music
own there we go some liquid drum and
bass man I love this music good tunes
good tunes um when and how do i think
Secret Wars 2015 will end who asked you
a question what we know it's going to
end in like September because it's only
an eight issue a storyline so it's
something like that um they released a
couple issues on the same month like I
think issues two and three and came out
in the same month and so I think that
you know it'll probably him by
September's so that being said I think a
lot of the characters that we know and
love are going to die off I think a lot
of universes are going to be killed off
there's gonna be some reorganizations
different things like that um I think
that like like a lot of the incredible
hulks are going to die off i think we're
only going to be left with like Bruce
Banner maybe you know doc Samson
Incredible Hulk I'm not really sure i
don't know i mean it'll be i don't know
i mean at this point it's real cute
tough to tell I mean they've announced
stuff you know what we're going to have
an all new avengers lineup and different
things like that but i think that you
know like like Peter Parker I don't
think is really going to be like this
spider-man anymore I think they're
moving in the direction of miles of
Milan switch it's about time you know
that they let Miles Morales take over
the role of spider-man the miles of my
let's become like these spider man you
know because I think that's been a long
time coming and I think a lot of
spider-man fans are kind of expecting
that and I don't think very many people
are upset about it unless you like a
hardcore Peter Parker fan which there's
you know there's a lot of them out there
I think a lot of people are you know
pretty psyched about the whole the whole
mouse mouse thing but again it's kind of
difficult to tell you know there are
characters that we know will continue on
like we know Jane Foster through where
will be the new Thor in the universe
going forward you know different things
like that but let's see Rob you you
should take the first part of the Red
Lantern Corps video we're learning video
and and post it instead of redoing it
for each Lantern Corps Madol no I mean
I'll get something figured out Rob gum
please it sounds for bad okay well
that's one complaint so out of like all
the people in here we'll see how many
people complain let's see thoughts on
Deadpool so far ah I mean it's dead
pulls secret secret war is basically
dead pool in the original Secret Wars
event um you know it's not that bad I
mean it's not terrible this is different
i will say that i think it's cool seeing
deadpool interjected into a into a whole
new environment i think that's really
sort of a weird thing first time in the
chat what's up what's up Ian it's cool
seeing Deadpool sort of thrust into a
story if it feels like a comic book
version of like Sonic and Knuckles you
know where you could like take a
knuckles Carter you could take the sonic
and knuckles game you could put like
Sonic 2 in it and all the sudden you
have knuckles and it just makes the game
better it's cool seeing Deadpool
insecure singer wars that being so
that's all we get so I think that Marvel
might be sort of analyzing things it may
this may just be a last hurrah for
Deadpool and after that's what was never
see Deadpool again it may be that you
know that it's a you know a test that
they're looking to see how well receive
the story will be and if it is what we
see they'll keep it going then they also
be looking at the movie if the movies
very well received you know it really
just kind of depends I think I don't
know exactly what Marvel has going on
behind the scenes but you know the whole
thing with Deadpool school I mean I'm
enjoying the story so far so
everyone says REE time runs out before
Secret Wars but can you tell me the
exact graphic novels please thanks um
just read New Avengers vol 3 and
Avengers vol 5 and that's really all you
mean yeah that's pretty much all you
need that is as far as I understand s
the entire time runs out of course I
think they do have a time runs out trade
paperback that you can get do I like
knuckles or shadow more definitely not
rules i grew up with knuckles like he's
a much better character i think a cooler
hair to go play with anyway what do you
think of the two wasp suit and the
ant-man movie um I kind of expected that
um you know with the interesting thing I
mean I don't really compare to the
comics because I wanted to the movie
expecting it to be different in the
comics I mean I didn't you know Scott
Lang's most notable moment in the comics
is when he got blown up so I guess aside
from his solo series right now anyway
but um I was kind of expecting something
different I think it's cool that the
wasp suit and the ant-man suit look
almost exactly the same except ones
designed for a woman and once the sign
for a man I didn't because in the comics
the way it's set up the the idea is that
Janet Van Dyne grows wings whenever she
shrinks like it's not until she actually
shrinks down into her wasps form that
she physically grows wings and I didn't
expect to see a character physically
grow wings that would be kind of you
know that it kind of silly but I think
that the idea is you know to have her
operate as more of a partner than a
sidekick and that's what I'm really
hoping the difference is I'm hoping
it'll introduce her is like a sidekick
like like you're you're a sidekick to a
man as opposed to fighting a long sigh
damn man I mean it looks like what
they're doing theirs are basically
building up the romance between Scott
I'm sorry between Hank Pym and the
original original Janet Van Dyne with
with Scott Lang and hope Van Daan so you
know the Hank Pam Janet Van Dyne
romances is cool I doubt we'll see Scott
Lang hit hope but nonetheless you know
um it'll be interesting to see how it
all plays out but nice hat thank you
it's the UK Wildcats had some huge UK
Wildcats fan I live in Kentucky what
would I be rob has all the swag all the
swag how much swag all the swags
you're gonna go see at man in like 10
minutes well you're going to be very
happy because the movie was really good
i really enjoyed it ant-man isn't really
like an action film per se it's a great
combination it's a great blend of like
action and comedy that being said it's
the best solo film for a character
that's not a sequel since Iron Man 1 so
it's pretty solid will Las be in the
civil war movie I don't think so i think
like there's a list i saw where they
were going through and they were
basically like debunking rumors and they
were saying like you know one of the
rumors is that was-- was going to be in
civil war I don't think she is I think
that she's expressed an interest in it
but I don't think she's going to be in
civil war if she did so if you did it'll
be kind of cool we started this about I
don't know about 10 minutes ago so
you're not late at all like you're only
I guess you're late but you're not so
late that we're getting ready to end it
or anything like that what am I vaping
today I am currently vaping um it's
called the player it's actually the the
company that makes it is called the exes
but this one's the player and it's a
tobacco flavor it's really really good
to its it's what is it um what all does
it have well it doesn't say it on here
but it's like it's tobacco and I think
saffron and like some nutmeg or
something like that I can't remember but
it's a really really good really good
flavor ant-man is a true in page flipped
in the book of a true fan page flippin
loot yeah basically i mean it's it's
flipping through the book of phase see
what it's like BAM ant-man and you're
like wow I mean it really took you by
surprise it took me by surprise I didn't
expect it to be as good as it is now I'm
sorry I didn't expected to be as good as
it is but now like I'm really psyched I
mean it was a great fun film to go see
and and I really enjoyed it you know I
think that was the biggest concern that
people had with with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in with the ant-man
film and you would think people would
know better by now you think I'd know
better by now but um I think they
concerned a lot of people had is that
the movie wasn't going to be as good as
as people thought of Miami because ma
was so obscure I mean mmm was such an
obscure character and he really is when
you look at Hank Pym henkins notable for
two things hitting his wife and making
Ultron and that's it I mean there's
really nothing more to him than that
he's never had a solo series you know
he's always been a backdrop to the
Avengers he's always the first person to
get beat up you know we talked about all
that stuff you know in my video and so
when mama came out and they said we're
making an ant-man film based on Scott
Lang people were like well I mean he'll
hang pims you know obscure enough you're
gonna pick Scott Lang and and I was kind
of a man but but you know I mean iron
man was more notable and so this is
about as obscure as marvel's gotten I
mean you know people will say guardians
of the galaxy was obscure but certainly
not because guardians of the galaxy gain
their notoriety after the annihilation
event and people were like huh look how
many people knew who star star Lord was
to a degree you know because of his solo
stories before people knew who vaca
Burakumin woods because of his solo
stories beforehand but we hadn't
actually seen him team up before and
watching you know reading the
annihilation event reading them getting
together and forming the team and
everything you know it is it's you know
people were like okay you know it was it
was people like I could see this
happening so you know Marvel fans knew
who the guardians of the galaxy were you
know I casual fans to a degree knew who
the guardians of the galaxy were in
casual fans to a degree knew who Scott
Lang was the problem was that Scotland
just wasn't known for anything and so it
was it was it was a great choice it was
a risky choice but it was a great choice
it was risky because it could have been
a total flop people could have been like
I don't know who that guy is and I don't
care and they're not going to go see the
movie but it would turned out to be a
really good gamble because you know it
paid off I mean it was a very
entertaining character so um let's see
Rob do you think Civil War is too
crowded and because of this people may
not like it that's a really good
question i've actually been you know
we've been having that conversation me
Benny and Sal and you know off and on
you know in the background we've been
talking periodically and you know a
couple people that I've compared to I
guess i'll talk to you know it's it's
one of those things where it's it
depends on how it's written the age of
Ultron was written clunk Lee you know
age of Ultron feels like it was written
sloppily like it was just kind of thrown
together like Marvel was like we need to
do something that's bigger than the
first Avengers film so let's just do
ultra on they just do it out there in
truth I still stick to the argument this
day that the the importance of age of
Ultron like you know that the conflict
with ultra on all that kind of stuff
that was distraction that was you know
an excuse to give us a movie about the
Infinity stones
and that's this that's what the movie
was about that movie was about the
Infinity stones you know Ultron was just
kind of there and some stuff happened
you know having said that I think that
with Captain America 3 you know what the
Russo brothers behind it and everything
is going to be much better organized I
think it's going to be better written
especially when you have an event like
Civil War now as far as i understand it
the movie itself is supposed to start
civil war it's not supposed to encompass
civil war so you know i could be wrong
but i'm pretty sure that's the case that
you know it basically launches a civil
war conflict that being said that would
be an awesome idea because imagine you
know you have the film's going forward
you have like Panther you have the
Inhumans you have you know Captain
Marvel so on and in the backdrop of all
that you have the ongoing conflict
between Captain America and Iron Man
that would be a great way to keep things
going a great way to keep keep things
fresh you know great way to keep things
exciting my current poll this is
everything from DC you and all the
secret worst ions you know but that that
is that's pretty solid um you know in
terms of of my view that being said if
it is just one movie if the entire civil
war conflict is encompassed in one movie
you know I amana Captain America become
enemies and they make up and it all
happens by the end of the film then it
will feel rushed then it will feel like
I'm sorry like Avengers 2 it will feel
like there's so much happening so fast
but again you know at this point I don't
know I mean there's there's really no
information out there about the script
aside from the fact that it's about Tony
Stark and Captain America fighting so
you know it's it's very difficult to
tell you know what all is going to
happen you know when the when the
trailers come out we start to get a
little more information when we sort of
figure out what's going on of course
I'll do a full trailer analysis there's
no way I wouldn't if ever I if there's
ever a movie that I will do a full
trailer analysis for it will be Captain
America 3 and you know once we get that
will get a lot more information will get
a much better idea of what's going on
but it doesn't come out until next year
and we're in the middle of the summer of
2015 so we got a while you know now I
mean you know with ant-man having now
been released and with Jessica Jones
coming out netflix and everything like
that I think that we will see I think
we'll see more happening with regards to
captain america will see more
information coming out because that's
the next big movie
captain america civil war I mean that's
the next big thing and so we're going to
see a lot more information being dumped
about the film we're gonna see a lot
more information coming out we're going
to see some trailers most likely some TV
spots and so on and and you know it'll
be cool so um Rob would you ever do a
video on Ice Man I mean at some point or
another I mean I'd like to do videos and
all the x-men but again you know it's
it's difficult to do where is the one
above all is he dying we don't know and
truthfully I don't think Hickman cares
so here's a really cool thing about
Jonathan Hickman I was watching an
interview that he was doing a chem Brule
as he was doing it with but he was doing
an interview and he was talking about
how he writes his stories and of course
Jonathan Hickman is doing sticker boys
right now Jonathan Hickman wrote time
runs out Jonathan Hickman did the story
that we just finished with franklin
richards and he said that the way that
he does his scripts the way he does his
stories is he has the ending laid out he
knows what he wants the ending to be and
from there he works forward and so
that's one of the reasons why the
stories are so intricate and so
well-written is because he doesn't start
from okay here's a catalyst let's go
from there and figure out the ending he
says here's the ending what do I want
everything to be that leads towards it
and so you know with with all that
having been said I think that it will be
I don't know I don't know I it's hard to
get my thoughts organized here it's hard
to get my thoughts I that's that's I
don't know that we'll all come back to
that thought later on so um let's see
uh-huh yeah i agree civil wars give me
the next week yeah i mean i don't know
why it wouldn't be i don't know i don't
know why it wouldn't be at all they said
civil war will be one movie i see i hope
it's not i think i think i'd be
disappointing I think it'd be what we've
gone over that a million times you know
that you know where I stand on that idea
of the Civil War I'm where I stand of
that idea of what you know how it's all
going to turn out let's see
there was a question oh yeah ok so
anyway so um so Sony went back here too
much about the one of them all because
I'm trying to make it a habit to not
skip over people's questions or not like
half answer their questions and move on
so anyway back to your question about
the one above all we don't know
truthfully the one above all is only
appeared a handful of times and I think
that what Hickman is going to do is just
kind of tell us that the what above all
is just there you know and and he's not
really going to worry about it he's
going to say this happening is just the
nature of all things everything comes
into existence everything's reborn and
so on and so forth I mean you know even
even though the Future Foundation story
the one we went over with Franklin
Richards there were there was a lot of
stuff that we left out because it didn't
pertain to what we were talking about
but that is basically a precursor to
time runs out it's basically a precursor
which is secret wars 2015 that all that
leads up to it they talk about the heat
death of everything they talk about the
end of all things I talk about Galactus
and franklin richards standing at the
end of all things and then green the new
universe as it comes along you know all
that kind of stuff and so you know what
on what the feeling that I that I think
we're going to have here is that at the
end of Secret Wars 2015 is basically
going to tie up the entire Fantastic
Four from from Jonathan Hickman time
runs out and Secret Wars 2015 I think
it's going to all be this one huge
encompassing story I could be wrong and
I may very well be but I think that's
kind of how it's going to play out
because that's how have been stories are
told everything leads into everything
else you know and so it'll be it'll be
interesting to see how it all plays out
um if the Living Tribunal is dead who
takes his or its place well he can
remember the function of the Living
Tribunal was to ensure that multiple
realities Jonathan Hickman explain the
18 yet I Hickman explained if we were to
do a if you were to do videos on
Hickman's entire run in Marvel Comics it
would literally take a year like it
would be nuts how in-depth all that
stuff goes but um this is your favorite
comics and coffee I'm glad you enjoy it
I'm glad you dig it um kinda forgot what
I was going to say before but anyway
yeah I'm pretty sure it'll all it'll all
sort of fold together it'll all come
together come together and it all makes
sense so
um let's see how the Civil War worked
with oh yeah I'm sorry time of the
Living Tribunal so other cm I get so
scatterbrained you know whenever I get
distracted like I guess so
scatterbrained so the purpose of the
Living Tribunal you have to remember is
that the Living Tribunal serve the
purpose of ensuring that all the multi
all the universes exists in balance so
the multiverse exists imbalance that no
one universe became a threat to the
other universes that no one universe you
know step out of that balance of power
different things like that and so like
say for example that someone found a way
to to use an infinity gauntlet in
another universe we know they can't but
let's say they did the Living Tribunal
would correct that that's the purpose
that he serves is to ensure everything
exists in balance because right now and
cigars to thousand and fifteen there is
no multiverse there will be later on
they will be alternate universes later
on Marvel's told us that but because
right now in this moment there is no
multiverse there's no need for the
Living Tribunal the living tribu the
purpose of living tribunal is served by
dr. doom dr. doom oversees all the
realities you know the purpose of the
one above all is served by dr. doom he
oversees all the realities every because
everything that's in existence right now
is thicker Wars is battle world that's
it there's nothing else out there and so
you know we'll that'll probably change
later on as the the new marvel universe
expands itself you know because that was
basically what secret wars was was
marvel you know consolidating all the
realities and saying we're starting our
multiverse from scratch right here this
is it and so on you know as things
progress in things change we'll probably
see the Living Tribunal reintroduce or
probably see the one above all up here
in some capacity then it could be that
you know Jonathan Hickman has all this
going in in this huge direction and
again you know we don't know where's the
original beyond her the last we knew the
original be honor was literally turned
into a cosmic you but right now we don't
know remember guys a lot of these
characters as far as it's explained
right now the Assumption we have to make
is this if the character has not made an
appearance and Secret Wars or has not
been referenced they don't exist that's
basically where we have to go right now
that's the that's the Assumption we have
to make if you don't see the character
in any of the times if you don't see the
character in the main Secret Wars event
they're dead they don't exist anymore
you know that's pretty much what we're
being told or at least as far as I
understand that's how I'm interpreting
it
um Rob who do you think is king of the
Nerds will wil wheaton Chris Hardwick
wil wheaton feel free i would say will
we probably I mean I grew up watching
him on Star Trek The Next Generation so
you know when he met the traveler and
took off to another plane of existence
or something like that let's see uh Rob
should you should have had a what-if
event for Robbie Baldwin if he if he
will be in Civil War Rob Robbie
Baldwin's I had that I hated that
character he was dumb I don't like him
at all I mean yeah I didn't like him at
all let's see doesn't anyone else is my
voice had to sing for you guys let me
know if my voice is out of sync it
shouldn't be let me know if it is what
am I one of my thoughts on MCU villains
um the problem that i have with with
Marvel Cinematic Universe villains is is
they're not relatable you know they're
they're formulaic and and that is the
inherent problem with with villains and
that was never more evident than with
with Darren cross and you know the in
the ant-man film you know with what the
Marvel Comics you can do a lot more with
villains you can spend a lot more time
making villains relatable you can spend
a lot more time making villains
intriguing you could spend a lot more
time developing them turning them into
something awesome with the comic or with
movies you can't do that with movies
like you establish villains villains
fight heroes and that's that the problem
that I think that model has okay cool if
it's good and everything that's cool the
problem that I think Marvel has is its
marvelous so focused on making an
expanded universe for heroes unlike the
Avengers and things like that that they
don't worry about the villains because
in truth the role the villains serve in
the film's is to give us the heroes
that's it the the purpose of you know
Obadiah Stane and iron man one was to
establish the fact that Tony Stark was
going from being a war profiteer to a
hero that was the role that Obadiah
Stane played you know the rule that
Darren cross played was to give Scott
laying the
perception of a hero to say here's why
Scotland's a hero he's fighting this guy
who's doing bad things and that's it I
mean that's that's the only role that
villains play in a Marvel Cinematic
Universe and it sucks you know because
in truth at this woman right now the
kingpin is the only villainous really
received great character development and
that's because they had 20 episodes you
know they had 20 hours effectively to
turn him into something awesome when you
have one tenth of that time you just
don't have the ability you don't have
that luxury to to make it something cool
you don't have that luxury to you know
develop a character that way and so
that's really kind of what Marvel is
really have to deal with you know that's
really where they're at their in a
position where they're creating heroes
and they need something to create a line
at you know to create a dichotomy they
need something to say here's a hero hero
villain and here's what defines the hero
because the hero it's what all the
stories are going towards I mean
everything's going towards the infinity
war and so they need us to know here's
why Kathryn America's a hero here's why
iron man's a hero here's why Captain
Marvel here's why Black Panthers so on
and so forth here's why you know Scott
Lang our heroes because they fight these
bad guys who do these things and so um
let's see Rob if you could have one
crossover between an anime character and
a Marvel character who would it be um oh
I'm in Goku obviously no not Goku Vegeta
Vegeta and The Incredible Hulk that
would be an awesome match up vegeta vs
The Incredible Hulk I think I've seen
that argument before on Comic Con but I
think that'd be a cool I can it be a
cool concept um let's see a witch clever
character has the most money I want to
say it's Black Panther i think i'd read
an article somewhere where somebody
broke down like all of the characters
and or yeah all the characters wealth
and they said that with with black
panther owning like an entire country
and owning a single source of like
elements for the world you like he's a
sole person that owns that that he's the
richest person it would be like someone
in the real world right now being like
the sole provider of oil
for the world like I'm the only one who
owns oil I'm the only one that like I
own the territory that has all the oil
you have to go through only me to access
that it would make me astronomically
wealthy that I think is is why black
pair there's a richest person after that
it falls into a culmination of things I
mean it's really just kind of broken
down because it's really difficult to do
I mean it's hard to compare you know is
turn these talk richer than then Bruce
Wayne well they're not in the same
universe and there's no way to know so
at that point it just comes down to who
you like more people who like Batman
more are going to be like Batman's
richer than Tony Stark and people who
like Tony Stark more going to be like
Iron Man's richer than Batman you know
and so on and so forth it just kind of
depends but but what we can't agree on
is that no one else in any of the
chemical territories owns an entire
country and as the sole provider of one
of them one of the rarest minerals in
the world so I think we can all agree
that Black Panthers probably the richest
person in comic books let's see if you
were flash Rob can you do with some can
you please do me a simple favor and
unblock my other channel if you were
trolling you probably got banned so the
questions so the answer that question is
no um yeah probably not I mean I don't
ban you unless you were trolling so have
you read ultimatum what did you think
about the version of Reed who is now the
maker you know I was thinking about that
you know I have a red ultimate I might
have widened read it all the way through
I was in a really big fan of the
Ultimate Universe that being said Reed
Richards as a villain is intriguing you
know Reed Richards as a bad guy is
interesting not interesting enough for
me to buy into it not interesting enough
for me to say man like I really find
that cool you know it's just and it's
you know I've never really been a big
fan of the Ultimate Universe to be
honest with you guys you know if I were
if i were to be truthful I've never been
a big fan of the Ultimate Universe I
never got into it you know I know Miles
Morales is popular and I know there are
elements of the Marvel Universe in the
Ultimate Universe that people love you
know and I'm bringing content based on
that stuff but for me you know I never
avidly sat down and read The Ultimate
Universe I never found that fascinating
because to me I always i liked the
origins that we got in the mainstream
Marvel Universe you know I like those
stories more than the
Ultimate Universe counterpart so let's
see Rob where do you rank ant-man with
other Marvel Cinematic Universe movies
oh man no you didn't get banned you got
blocked well okay um send me a message
with your channel name yeah banhammer he
who is not worthy yet whosoever trolls
my channel if he be caught shall possess
the power of the banhammer um i would
say that with the movies that have come
out that have come out so far you know
when it comes to 22 solo films with
number ones i guess you know the first
of the solar fields between Iron Man 1
Thor Captain America one all that kind
of stuff ant-man comes right after I oh
man 1 he comes right after that I mean
it's Iron Man 1 ant-man and then you
know Captain America Thor so on and so
forth if you're talking about all the
movies that have been made so far and
man's not right that high i mean i'd say
i'll top my head the number one movie
that i have is it's going into the
galaxy well no I'm sorry iron man
because that started the whole Marvel
Cinematic Universe after that comes
guardians of the galaxy probably captain
america the winter soldier you know and
then after that it kind of breaks down
Avengers and then maybe amen it kind of
depends but let's see rob is the MCU
going to be a combination of verse 6 16
in the Ultimate Universe not really I'm
think of the MCU is a totally different
reality it's completely separate you
know it's it's totally gone there's you
know a whole different a whole different
you know Kimberly and we know that for a
couple reasons we know that because one
in the alternate universe you know it
sounds so eloquently pointed out and one
of his videos on back issues that that
Hank am I basically like beat his wife
savagely you know the relationship
between him and Janet Van Dyne and the
ultimate universe is vastly different
than the universe that we see right now
with the marvel cinematic universe and
the relationship between Hank Pam and n
Janet Van Dyne so we know way off the
bat it's it's not a combination of the
two it's totally separate and that's
basically how it exists you know and
more
Alexis basically the setup is that is do
our thing cut out for some reason huh
okay nothing stopped going live for some
reason hopefully I didn't freak out but
now that they're totally separate
universes they're there you know
completely different in terms of of what
they offer you know so so think of it as
like by ear 616 University Ultimate
Universe and then the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's completely separate so
yeah the MCU has a number it's it's 19
is 19 99 99 or something like that i can
remember it's one digit short of 200,000
so um Miles Morales versus Peter Parker
actually Miles Morales Peter Parker is a
cool character but the history of Miles
Morales has far more in depth the
history of ma's well it's is far more
intriguing to me so i love i love the
character of Miles Morales I think he's
much better let's see what do you think
we saw in ant-man and Scott links helmet
on a second now who do you think we saw
in scotland's helmet in the Microverse
any chance of it being eternity what
what are you talking about I didn't
catch that okay I got to do some
research home second like we're going to
do well no I'm not gonna worry about
that but I'm gonna do some research um
and and look around because that sounds
really intriguing that sounds really
cool hmm top three DC titles right now
Batman Superman and I'm probably
Starfire I say yes Holly my my top for
you right now is there a bigger role is
there a bigger role for Howard the Duck
oops let me scroll back up
is there a bigger role for howard the
duck in the MCU for a laugh I hoped on
howard the duck is a goofy character it
looked like that looked like eternity
huh I'm gonna have to look that up then
because I know how some of you guys are
I know some of you guys are just like
hey like if like if a light shined this
way and if he turns his head that
direction and if the stars align and the
planets are all in this one particular
location you can obviously see thats
eternity I love you guys for it like
y'all's speculation and stuff is is
funny to me but you know there's been
some times where you guys are just so
far off its weird so um hey Rob do you
uh do you like Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
I like him yeah I like him too like Hugh
Jackman is a great Wolverine which I'm
curious to see like who's gonna play
Wolverine after he's gone I'm I'm
genuinely curious to see how that's
gonna play out you know but unless I
really enjoy I really enjoy Hugh Jackman
as Wolverine um lawl i hope not howard
the duck doesn't belong no he doesn't
definitely dr. doom in termina eternity
room was there dude like like Larry
Bronson is so sure like to rob you he
was there man like I know he was there
like I'm so sure like he was there who
do I think could be the main villain a
doctor strange I probably say more dough
I think morta will be the main villain I
mean he was the first villain he's the
original veal on the main villain for
dr. strange so I don't know why it would
be anybody else do her mom moves too big
at this point Dermod me was like a
multiversal threat you know and so he's
way too big to introduce on the first
film Rob do a video on eternity will
apparently have to now if eternity was
in which which rob you know um Rob I'm
dying for vs Superman who would win okay
we'll talk about that here in a second
um but no like like I mean if he turned
he was in and man that I guess we have
to talk about that now because you know
it's weird which by the way like I don't
know okay someone explain this to me
like why are you guys so big on cosmic
entities why do you guys love cosmic
entities so much because because here's
a funny thing I'd love
you guys questions like I love asking
you all questions in these cute i said i
know you guys love it I know you got
like I know you guys love it you guys
love being asked questions like I don't
you dig it so um let's see hey Rob can
we vote on what you explained in your
other channel right now I mean it's this
is my main channel so so Rob explains is
just kind of what interests me I explain
whatever happens to be interesting to me
you know at the time so let's say Rob do
you wish the MCU superheroes were as
powerful as in the comics not really I
like the idea that they are more
grounded i like the idea that they're
more like like base basic you know i
like the more that like the idea that
they're more human you know yes Robert
Boles yes go Kentucky Wildcats I like
the idea that they are more reasonable
and may seem like a more realistic
depiction like that is something that I
prefer more okay so back to me is back
for the other person's question 4 vs
Superman hmm well and the marvel vs DC
crossover odin allowed Superman to wield
Thor's hammer so let's say that cause is
not in there and that Superman cannot
wield Thor's hammer that means you can't
take it away from them I would say that
that it actually be a draw Thor's hammer
is really really powerful but I would
say that you know that I would say that
it would be a standstill I think that
that Thor would be able to pummel
Superman with a sword but I'm sorry with
us with his hammer but Thor's only got
to find out I'm an Avenger he doesn't
have an infinite amount of energy we
know that because he could be destroyed
as long as the Sun is replenishing
themselves a Superman he's going to have
enough energy to fight and so it kind of
depends but at the same time as you guys
are pointing out Thor has magic on his
side he has a power of years you know he
has magic and so you know i don't know
it's really tough to tell um i would say
that off the top of my head if i had to
make a choice right here and now and if
i had to pick someone i'd say probably
Superman would win but okay that's my
question to you guys the Thor versus
Superman who do you all pick like who do
you guys who you guys think would win in
a battle which
and if Superman cannot pick up Thor's
hammer then who would win in a battle
between the two why do I hate spider-man
because he's boring so I think he's
boring anyway with all the MCU movies is
there a character that you think is
missing from the movies TV netflix shows
another punish will be in daredevil and
probably his own series the century
Robert Reynolds a century I think needs
to be in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
mm-hmm Superman hands down Thor
obviously before the draw Superman yes
you people are throwing up all kinds of
answers so the almighty Thor Superman
Beach Thor but it's close yeah I don't
know do you think soo i think the
spider-man will die in the MCU and it
allowed them to bring in miles miles I
don't know but I know that Kevin foggy
said that like because they asked him
about that you know they were asking
about Miles Morales and you know it was
an interview that he had i think it was
it was a video interview maybe was
coming Book Resources I gianna remember
who it was but um they had asked him you
know what made you choose between like
what made you choose Peter Parker over
Miles Morales says Miles Morales is
equally as well known and probably
equally as light as s Peter Parker and
the Marvel Comics and I think for them I
think Emma Peggy foggy so that they
chose to use Peter Parker because of the
fact that you know he's the name has
been seen already you know he's like
people know who he is and in a true that
makes sense you know we've had multiple
Peter Parker films and if Marvel is
going to you know reboot the spider-man
franchise and makes sense to use Peter
Parker because he was the original
spider-man that having been said it's
time to let him go it's time to let
Peter Parker go it's time to put him out
to pasture you know it's I think that it
would be a great decision to kill off
Peter Parker and infinity war and allow
miles miles to take his
that would be an awesome idea you know
having said that I don't know how they
would out what happen I mean how would
you explain Miles Morales becoming Peter
Parker becoming spider-man and you can't
have a spider but the you can't have the
spider bite you know in the movies you
couldn't do that because people would be
like well that's lame you know you'd
have to do something different but you
know there's a lot of things they can do
with a smarter man mythology you know if
Marvel has the rights to it again that
being said um we don't know if if you
know spider-man if Marvel's ability to
make spider-man films is limited to one
spider-man film we don't know if at
least I don't know if they have to stick
with Peter Parker like if if spider-man
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe due to
some contractors and like that he has to
be a like a straight white high school
kid you know we don't know that or at
least I don't know that I'm there may be
people out there that do or there may be
you know stuff out there you know
because information out there that I
hadn't looked up but um you know in
truth if Marvel has the ability to
basically have like free reign over how
they create spider-man you know and and
how they help Sony make the film I think
it's time to go ahead and and jump into
you know Miles Morales I think it's time
to go ahead and give my house my Alice's
do so no way Sony let's Peter died if
it'll I mean if it will reinvigorate
interest in the series of course I'll
let them dry they'll do whatever it
takes to make money you know and if they
say like we're bringing in a black
spider-man that's going to turn a lot of
heads and it's going to raise a lot of
eyebrows and people are going to say
what's interesting you know some people
going to freak out they're gonna be like
oh my god we can't have a black
spider-man whatever it's a 21st century
is time to move on folks but you know I
think that that you know that is
important is important to explore the
existence of miles wireless outside
comic books so um let's see what big
events from that question got moved up
what big events from comics would you
think would be good for a movie oh god
that's a great question if I had to
choose if I had to choose an event in
the comics for a film
Rob you are flipping awesome i
appreciate if i had to choose between if
i had to choose any of the events that
are available in Marvel Comics to make a
movie out of I would choose I would
choose a thanos imperative and the
reason why I choose the famous
imperative is because you could use any
reason for the opening of the rift you
could to say well because of the
infinity war there's a fault that's been
opened like a tear that's been opened
between our universe and the cancer
verse and that's that's the only
explanation you need I mean in the
comics it was an I'm sorry was it was
the war of kings you know i'm pretty
sure that caused that but um you know in
and in the movies you could say it's
anything and so then you could say well
now like we've got an alternate universe
spilling into our own and it would
create it would it would really set a
good standard because it would give
Marvel a chance to explore alternate
realities it would give all the chance
to explore you know how receptive
moviegoers would be to the introduction
of alternate realities and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it'd be a great you
know it'd be a great idea i rewrite
concept um you're either way I think
it'd be you know it'd be cool you know
it would be it'd be a cool thing to see
and I'll be down with it you know but I
think that it would because I mean you
you have all the elements of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right now you got
Thanos you got mistress death you have
the Avengers you have the guardians of
the galaxy you know and you can
introduce evil versions of these
characters and it would it would go
along great I think it'd be the best
choice but again there's a lot of other
stories you could you could do
earthbound stories you know maximum
security you know different things like
that and so it kind of depends but let's
see did you restart a star Lord and
Kitty Pryde number one if so what do you
think I'd already yet but he says it's
really good I haven't read it um he said
it would I really liked it suggested
that I read it and then he hasn't been
wrong so far you know he he mentioned
that he really enjoyed the what was it
the Arsenal and red hood team up and I
was on the fence about it and I checked
it out and I was like this is actually
pretty solid it's actually pretty
interesting so so wyd nuggets so yeah
I'm mini is pretty good when it comes to
suggesting stories to read what's your
what's my favorite comic my favorite
comic is actually a series and it's the
five or six part series of this
tree rubber Reynolds so let's see you
the Joker Joker is Jason Todd theory um
I've seen that I actually first I first
heard about it on a mergency awesome
when he was talking about it on Twitter
in his youtube channel and because i
watch his youtube channel i watch a lot
of YouTube channels for comic book
youtubers and and not coming book
youtubers as well like a lot of called
any channels and destiny channels and
stuff like that but I'm which by the way
if you guys ever get a chance go check
out the loyal patriot like look up the
loyal patriot on on youtube like he's
he's solid like he's you guys think that
my voice is good the loyal patriot has
an amazing voices voices super deep like
hey guys it'll be here like it's it's
nuts but he's a really he's a really
cool guy he uploads periodically a lot
of this game play call of duty but he's
a really cool guy to ditch you i think
he's got a twitch stream to like the oil
patriot on twitch and he usually plays
dayz so it's really fun to go over there
and hang out but anyway um you know i
first heard about that on emergency
awesomes youtube channel and it was it's
interesting to me but i think he
debunked it and i think he said that you
know there's a scar on the on the chest
like a bullet entry on the chest plate
of the armor but there's no scar on the
Joker's chest and so i think he was kind
of like that it's basically you know
telling us that that's not jason to cod
um having said that like let's say for
example that that he's wrong that that
emergency awesome isn't correct which is
usually rare he's usually pretty right
but let's say the you know for whatever
reason they decide to add it in later on
and you know they end up depicting that
that would be awesome like that'd be
awesome to have Jason Todd as the Joker
you know it'd be a great descent I mean
that'd be a great story I mean imagine
that that Batman's being taunted
constantly Batman's being you know being
hounded you know messages being left and
stuff like that and instead of Jason
Todd being the Red Hood Jason Todd's the
Joker that would be an amazing concept
god I don't wanna surprise that hasn't
been done already i don't think it's
been done already but it'll be a cool to
be a cool idea Oh Tyrone Magnus taro
Magnus is solid dude I loved her own
magnets like for those of you guys who
don't know the entire on Magnus does
reaction videos and this channel is
blowing up like
easy but he does reaction videos for all
kinds of stuff and and I loved like his
whole his whole thing it was it was
pretty hilarious like he did the
reaction video to spider-man to Kevin
foggy talked about spider-man that's how
I found his channel and he's been solid
ever since top three youtubers Wow top
three favorite youtubers number one is
probably seananners number two is
probably Tyrone Magnus and number three
is emergency awesome i'd say probably in
that order are the three channels that I
dig the most let's see you pitch for an
MCU movie with silver surfer and
Galactus interacting with oh my pitch
for that man i don't know i mean a pitch
for Galactus in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a pitchfork Allah okay okay a
pitch for Galactus in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe all right let's say
that right now everything in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is earthbound for the
most part with the exceptions of
guardians of the galaxy it's all
earthbound um let's say that with
guardians of the galaxy that it was like
you would have to segue with the
guardians of the galaxy I mean there's
no other no other way you can do that
you would have to introduce Galactus and
the Silver Surfer with the guardians of
the galaxy we could go the route of
saying well silver surfers rosal to
earth one day and since collection is
coming but that's that's not you know
that's not interesting that's not
intriguing that's boring that's been
done before and I wouldn't like that so
let's say that um that you have God
let's see so let's say you have the
guardians of the galaxy off doing their
own thing fighting somebody or you know
whatever and let's say that you know
over the course of movies it's subtle
over the course of movie it's subtle
it's never a big thing they never make
it a huge thing but planets are being
destroyed they're being consumed let's
say this happens over the course of like
phase 2 or phase 3 or whatever it is you
know that periodically those
like a scene in the movie or maybe
they'll feature something on the
guardians of the galaxy whatever the
case may be but there'll be something to
indicate to us that planets are being
wiped of their inhabitants and they're
being drained of their you know of their
life energies whatever the case may be
now immediately we would pick up on that
is that's probably Galactus the only
person that would do something like that
but they give it to us in a way that it
could also be fan owes to that maybe
it's Thanos going about destroying you
know Drazen worlds basically you know in
an effort to locate all of the other
Infinity stones the final we get around
to infinity war the infinity war event
takes place the infinity war event draws
the attention of the silver surfer who
at the time was unaware of the planet
Earth you know because this is a
universe you know young universe
spanning event you know it of course
draws the attention draw the attention
of Galactus of the other cosmic entities
so on and so forth you know at that
point given the idea of capable of
powerful characters where they hail from
the Silver Surfer would somehow or
another be drawn to the planet Earth you
know and after being drawn to the planet
Earth of course you would someone go
like this again that's off the top of my
head is a quick pitch nothing too
spectacular I mean I pitches and all
that great but you know um that would be
you know just running things off how I
would kind of draw things in but let's
see will Deadpool ever end up with death
like for reals I don't know yeah I play
halo periodically um I could see
Deadpool ending up with mistress death
like that would be to be cool I mean I'd
be down with that I mean you know I
don't know but either either way you
know I would I would dig it you know I'd
be into it um let's see Rob my other
channel is 224 Vic ok I'll look it up
and see what's see what's up um let's
see uh thoughts on x-men Fantastic Four
movie crossover it makes sense i mean i
think the fox if they did that they be
looking at the whole like you know the
marvel cinematic universe right now the
success of the marvel cinematic universe
and they be doin the same thing you know
one of others is like oh we got to cash
in on this crossover thing and they be
buying into it but let's see if Galactus
is not within the MCU who is a cosmic
being
a population control if there is such a
being um I would say the probably isn't
one I mean I wouldn't know because
remember the purpose of Galactus serves
in the Marvel Comics before you know the
clutch everything is he consumed the
world's that how celestial eggs they
were basically being used to create new
Celestials and that's how the gala
that's how the universe was kept in
check from having like a litany of
Celestials is he can assume the world
where they would be worn on the Galactus
seeds so that's what you want to call it
but but no I mean that you know that's
really not an element here in the marvel
cinematic universe was really don't need
for him to be honest let's see do you
think instead of let's go back up do you
think instead of replacing Hugh Jackman
as well rain fox will kill off Logan em
entries x-23 as a new Wolverine that
would make sense and I would dig it I
mean I'd watch it I'd be into it but I
mean you know I don't know I mean in
exit like a Wolverine like character
needs to exist and the x-men I mean I
can't imagine them having no version of
Wolverine whatsoever so the Living
Tribunal and infinity wars my thoughts
well having the Living Tribunal in the
marvel cinematic universe will be a
great way to bridge the gap between the
model cinematic universe and the comics
it would be a great way to do that you
know but at this point with sakura wars
being lost I'd say it's probably too
late I mean you know assuming that again
multiple universes are born and assuming
in the comic so they tie into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it would make sense
the problem is that comics that exist
because there are comics that exists for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe they never
so well like they never do well because
no one really cares what goes on behind
the scenes some people just like I want
to see what happens in the movie you
know and and unless it's like a huge
film you know like they had a coming of
a prelude to the age of Ultron which I
made a video on it and uploaded it but
nobody really seemed to watch it I don't
think people really care that much so
you know let's see what are your
interests outside comics vaping and
gaming yeah hanging out with friends and
chilling you know going to the gym so on
and so forth you know that kind of stuff
so let's see
Rob if I could direct a Marvel movie and
it had to be new characters what comic
characters would you do and who would
the casts be also what would the plot be
and would Stanley make a cameo that is a
big question um that is a big question I
guess a series of questions um that I'm
gonna have to answer another time
because I'm that would take a while that
could be an entire video in and of
itself um let's see well I mean let's
jump into that let's let's talk about
that um let's see characters that I
would use well I'd use Robert riddles a
century that would be my story you know
my story would be the introduction of
Robert Reynolds a century into the
marvel cinematic universe and the idea
would be you know who was Robert who's
Robert Reynolds you know who is the
century you know people would like it
would literally be a story where he
travels throughout the Marvel Cinematic
Universe coming into contact with Reed
Richards with not really reread he's not
in there were coming into contact with
like spider-man coming into contact with
the Incredible Hulk with Captain America
with iron man saying like we knew each
other before like why do you not
remember me you know and and eventually
would all come together and it would all
you know make sense I mean if you guys
have a red eye go read you know the
ureta paulding is in jail East this
century which you can read it on on a
Marvel unlimited but go read that
limited series and that would be my
story and of course Stanley would make a
cameo so no I didn't read the aden see
the goku vs superman two cats tiger-cats
or this is the Kentucky Wildcats had so
who likes a century he sucks I like the
century and you suck I know it's it's
getting kind of personal but what's your
favorite food well that's not personal
at all I'm Chinese for definitely
Chinese food is amazing let's see do you
think that you think that Illuminati
group will exist in the MCU no I don't
think well I don't think mohabbat
Illuminati I don't think we'll have one
what's more powerful heart of the
universe or the Infinity Gauntlet
um definitely the heart of the universe
I mean it's explicitly stated that the
heart of the universe is far more
powerful because the heart of the
universe is the embodiment of power
whereas the Infiniti gone unless you
manipulate power so let's see i see you
east smoke are you smoking to quit
smoking cigarettes and I understand if
you can't answer but do you handle smoke
weed and I use my e-cig to initially get
off cigarettes but now I just enjoy it
just fun habit to have you i recommend
marvel unlimited or comic bento marvel
unlimited definitely so burn so edgy do
you think we do you think we have ave in
a movie before twenty thirty i think so
i think they'll make a venom movie at
some point just because venom is a big
name venom is well known and people will
go see it but uh you know I I don't
think it'll be good to be honest and
less Marvel's backing it if Marvel's
making it it'll be solid but if normal
is not making it I don't think it'll be
very good am I the only one or are you
the only one who thinks phase 4 will
have the doctor Avengers no I think
we'll see the Dark Avengers and phase 4
I mean you've already got spider-man ski
you can bring in Norman Osborn and you
can bring in hammer and you can have him
launch his own Dark Avengers I mean it
would make sense you know some kind of
antithesis I mean you can even say the
Dark Avengers our response to the
Avengers you know with civil war you can
even turn around and say the Captain
America instead of being a Secret
Avengers that is the Dark Avengers it
depends on how they want to spin the
movie but let's see hey Rob I'm a huge
fan well thank you Thank You Eugene I
appreciate it all right guys um we're
gonna go ahead and wrap this this live
Q&A session up I need to get to work on
on on the red red lantern the Red
Lantern Corps my brings in a million
places but if you guys don't follow me
on periscope make sure you guys follow
me there because I was periscoping
earlier you know what I had for the
script so far and you get a lot of
behind-the-scenes stuff you know and and
so on but uh but I you know if you don't
know how to follow me on periscope to
follow me on twit on Twitter and I go
live on periscope all the time people
will tell you like I'm always on pair
scope and so you can follow me that way
but um but yeah so anyway we're gonna go
ahead and run this up and and I will
catch you guys later peace